ich habe den günstigsten 992 GT3
Deutschlands gekauft und den über die
letzten Wochen versucht wieder zu einem
funktionsfähigen Auto zusammenzubauen
und nachdem wir in der letzten Folge an
den Kühlern gescheitert sind und das
Auto noch nicht fahrbereit war kümmern
wir uns hoffentlich heute genau darum
und schließen das Projekt ab ich wünsche
euch also viel Spaß mit der sechsten
Folge des GT3
Umbaus es ist soweit die letzte Station
ein letztes Mal das Auto von A nach
bringen jetzt geht die Karre ins Porsche
Zentrum nach Trier wo die airwgs
eingebaut werden wo alle Fehler gelöscht
werden wo wir uns um die Kühler kümmern
und wo das Auto dann in wenigen Tagen
fertig ist und ich ein fertiges Finales
Auto habe mit dem ich fahren kann
deswegen verladen ab nach Trier und
anfangen zu
[Musik]
arbeiten dier das ist jedes mal so ein
F
das hat doch spitzenmäßig funktioniert
oder in dem Licht wieer hier schon so
steht ne das ist so
krank ich feier das auch so ab vem ist
das jetzt das echte Mann halt die Fresse
das ist jetzt das echte Finale also wir
sind so kurz davor ich bin schon am
Fahren ich bin den Wagen gerade schon
gefahren und ich habe schon gespürt so
krank deine Sitzposition gefät mir
gerade ja das geil ne ich habe ja
überlegt weil hier ohne Sitz kann man
das jetzt perfekt sehen hier Bett rein
und dann machen wir große
Tour ich denke es ist kein Geheimnis
wenn ich sage dass die Werkstatt über
die letzten Wochen wirklich zu meinem
zweiten zu Hause geworden ist in den
meisten Fällen von morgens bis abends am
Auto arbeiten und das weg von zu Hause
raus aus meinem Rhythmus das mit dem
Schlaf ist schon nicht immer einfach zu
Kontroll Keren aber vor allem möchte ich
mir dann auch nicht noch weiter Gedanken
um mein Essen machen müssen und genau
solche Situationen sind die wo ich
meistens zu einer fettigen ungesunden
Variante greife die mich dann noch mehr
müde macht damit genau das nicht mehr
passiert gibt es glücklicherweise Hul
den Partner des heutigen Videos es ist
ein offenes Geheimnis dass ich
Trinkmahlzeiten lieb gerade eben weil
sie ready to drink sind und alle
wichtigen Nährstoffe einer Mahlzeit
enthalten muss mir in der Werkstatt
keine unnötigen Gedanken ums Kochen
machen oder geschweige denn irgendwas
bestellen ich bekomme in einer Flasche
hle genau das was ich in dem Moment
brauche echte pflanzliche Zutaten 26
Vitamine und Mineralien wenig Zucker und
viel Protein eine ausgewogene Mahlzeit
in einer Flasche die fast so schmeckt
wie ein Milchshake das beste man trinkt
sich nie an einer Sorte satt denn mit
vielen verschiedenen
Geschmacksrichtungen im rebergal wie
Schoko Berry oder IC coffee hat man
immer die freie Wahl auf was man gerade
am meisten Lust hat oder was am besten
passt klickt also jetzt auf den ersten
Link in der Videobeschreibung und checkt
das aus oder testet euch im Revo um die
Ecke durch die verschiedenen h Sorten
vielen Dank an Hul für die Unterstützung
dieses Projektes und euch viel Spaß
weiter mit dem Video das ist wirklich
unglaublich für mich jetzt sieht das
Auto auch mal wirklich nach was aus und
wirkt so wie es wirken soll richtig
krank das aller allerwichtigste zuerst
hinten ducktail schon wieder runter
alles was wir brauchen und jetzt mit der
ultraam Maschine die
vakuumbefüllung des kühlersystems
bedeutet wenn das jetzt alles so
funktioniert und es kein weiteres
Problem gibt mit Kondensator nee was
soll Thermostat Thermostat bedeutet das
dass das Auto wieder komplett vernünftig
läuft kühlt und und alles wunderbar ist
funktioniert das nicht potenziell das
Thermostat kaputt oder irgendwas was
dann wieder Verzögerung und Scheiße
bedeuten würde to to to hoffen wir es
nicht wir befüllen die Karre holen erst
alles raus befüllen dann wieder neu dann
geht's
ab unser Problem beim letzten Mal war
dass wir ein zu kleinen Kompressor
hatten der hat nicht genug Leistung
bekommen aber der kann's jetzt
aha so genau 19 l hier im Tank wenn der
Robin diesen Hebel betätigt dann geht
die Post
ab und jetzt läuft die ganze Schose hier
in die Karre
rein und am Ende funktioniert das
hoffentlich
alles mit der Handpumpe probiert Robin
gerade die letzten Reste aus dem ganzen
Kühlsystem zu holen die wir nicht haben
wollen also an Luft damit wir weiter
mehr Kühlmittel reinmachen können so
dass wirklich überall hingeht und dann
drück sich quasi alles einmal bis an die
letzte Stelle nach hinten durch so
kriegen wir kommen wir zum gewünschten
Ergebnis W was sagen n ja ne war korrekt
Käffchen so und während hier das
Kühlmittel reinläuft gibt ein zweites
Gerät für das Kältemittel also es ist
quasi ein unterschiedlicher Kreislauf
für die Klimaanlage richtig anderes
Mittel so ein gasähnliches Zeug ja und
mit diesem Gerät wird das hier dann
alles wieder befüllt sowas ist natürlich
hinterhofmäßig
nicht so richtig möglich oder ne
[Musik]
schwierig dieses Gerät ist master of
disaster das hilft uns dabei das Auto zu
verstehen dem Auto zu sagen was es zu
sein hat einzelnen Stellgliedern und
Elementen zu sagen wo sie zu sein haben
Wer sie sind was sie machen sollen dass
sie nicht kaputt sind und trotzdem zu
sagen wenn was kaputt ist also dieses
Ding kann mit dem Auto kommunizier
besser als wir und genau das tut es
jetzt und dann können wir genau sehen wo
vielleicht noch kleine Sachen sind die
wir bisher übersehen haben bzwise alles
wieder in den Normalzustand bringen z.B
Klappensteuerung ist eingebaut ist
angeschlossen alles wunderbar aber die
Klappe steuert nicht deswegen sagen wir
dem Ding jetzt hey du bist eine Klappe
du hast so und so zu stehen dann sollte
das auch alles wieder funktionieren und
das eben für quasi jedes einzelne Kabel
jede einzelne Funktion wir hatten
basically alles auseinander deswegen
gilt's dem Auto jetzt einmal zu zu sagen
hier so sieht's aus und so hast du das
zu machen dann funktioniert hoffentlich
alles ach ja und klimazeug ist drin
kühlermittel auch und auch das
kühlmittelzeug ist jetzt auch noch mal
Thema mit diesem
Computer alter das ist so laut und dann
hieß es Daumendrücken wir haben dem Auto
immer wieder leichte Gasstöße gegeben
nicht nur um den Wagen auf Temperatur zu
bekommen und zu gucken ob der Wagen
tatsächlich vernünftig kühlt sondern
auch um die Kühlflüssigkeit einmal
komplett durch System zu drücken sollte
dieser zweite Versuch die Kühler zu
befüllen wieder nicht dazu führen dass
das Auto vernünftig gekühlt wird haben
wir ein größeres Problem als gedacht und
der Finalisierung des Projektes steht
wieder was im Weg aber all das ohne
Erfolg die Leitungen bleiben kalt also
auch das erneute befüllen hat uns keine
kühlerlösung gebracht das Auto wird zu
warm pumpt nicht vernünftig durch was
auch immer
Mist also richtiger Mist letzter Option
die uns zumindest teilweise sinnvoll
erschien war dass wir ein fehlerhaftes
Thermostat haben das Thermostat ist
eigentlich dafür da den Kühlmittel
Durchfluss im gesamten Kühlsystem zu
regeln wird das Auto also zu warm sagt
das Thermostat okay auf lässt das
Kühlmittel durchfließen und kühlt den
Wagen wenn das nicht passiert wenn wir
kein Durchfluss haben wenn vorne die
Kühler nicht wirklich warm werden und
wir das Gefühl haben dass da irgendwas
passiert dann kann es gut sein dass es
das Thermostat ist auf der anderen Seite
sitzt genau dieses Teil auf der
Unterseite hinten unterm Motor und da
gab's kein Aufprall da ist nichts
passiert es gibt also keinen wirklichen
Grund warum dieses Teil kaputt sein
sollte auf der anderen Seite ist alles
ordnungsgemäß installiert alle Kühler
sind vernünftig installiert wir können
Unterdruck erzeugen bedeutet das gesamte
Kühlsystem ist dicht wir haben es
genauso befüllt wie es befüllt werden
muss das macht Robin ja nicht zum ersten
Mal sondern jeden Tag also kann es fast
nur das Thermostat sein also neues Teil
bestellen hoffen dass es rechtzeitig
ankommt und vor allem aber hoffen dass
es unser Problem löst ja schon wieder
ein neues Teil bestellen schon wieder
ein neues Teil bestellen dass ich vorher
nicht mit einberechnet hat wie viel mich
der Wagen und der gesamte Umbau jetzt
Schluss endlich gekostet hat erfahrt ihr
im nächsten Video vergesst also nicht
den Kanal zu abonnieren denn es gibt
auch noch weitere Pläne mit dem Auto
dazu aber im nächsten Video mehr aber
erstmal weiter an anderer Stelle Tag
Nummer 2 und während ich noch im Hotel
Sitze und die Moderation des letzten
Videos für euch aufnehme fängt Robin
schon mal an am Auto zu arbeiten guten
Morgen aus dem Porsche Zentrum Trier
heute steht noch einiges an ich fange
schon mal an es 8 Uhr und Dave kommt
gleich nach also vor heute auf dem Plan
stehen die Airbags einzubauen und den
Innenraum wieder zu komplettieren also
zu allererst mal hier oben den Dach
immer lösen natürlich damit man hier
außen an die curon Airbags auch gut dran
kommt weil sonst ist jetzt zu wenig
Platz zu allererst dann noch die
Batterie abklemmen weil wenn die
Batterie angeklemmt ist sind die Airbags
ja die ganze Zeit scharf also es liegt
die ganze Zeit Spannung an und die
könnten theoretisch zünden wenn halt
irgendein Parameter gesetzt wird oder
halt durch ein ungewünschten Zufall dass
irendw ein Funke überspringt oder sogar
durch die statische Aufladung des
Körpers oder von einer Kleidung kannst
du die Airbags schon zünden wenn du nur
an die Kabel kommt im schlechtesten Fall
so der dachhimel ist jetzt abgesenkt
jetzt am besten Blick auf das Carbondach
und natürlich auf die Seiten Airbags die
geht es jetzt auszubauen hier ausgepackt
ist der
neue Kopf Airbag für den es interessiert
wie es funktioniert also das hier ist
der sogenannte Gasgenerator da ist der
elektrische Anschluss zum zünden und da
ist ein Zünder drin und hier ist ein
Sprengstoff drin bin von Sekunden wird
dann hier vorne wenn vorne ein Crash
ausgelöst wird schickt das Steuergerät
hier in Strom rein das zündet hier drin
die Ladung und dann geht hier durch das
röhchen das Gas in diese airbagtasche
hier rein und die plätt sich dann auf
die Anlage kann man eigentlich so als
kontrolierte Rohrbombe verstehen und ja
das bauen wir jetzt ein den Sitz ich
schon mal aufgemacht jetzt kommt der
seiteng für den Fahrersitz rein das ist
der hier und zwar direk hinter dem
polzträger ist und festgeschraubt an
Metallhalter und dann Fall eines
aufbreit wie man halt gesehen hab reiß
dann hier auf den Sitzbezug haben wir
neu gekauft dann plät sich hier der
Seiten der Weg auf und schützt dann eben
den Fahrer vor dem seiteneinschlag ja
den schraube ich jetzt da rein und dann
kann der Sitz dann später wieder
komplett ins
[Musik]
Auto so Robin kämpft mit dem Innenraum
aber ziemlich erfolgreich das sieht
schon alles wieder nach Auto aus was für
ein Traum ich habe hier gerade irgendw
heißluftfö die beiden Sitze gemacht um
in bei dem alten Sitz also dem nicht
neubezogenen die ganzen Falten und so
vom Sitzen rauszumachen und bei dem
neuen einmal das neue Leder anzupassen
und das sieht richtig gut
[Musik]
aus alles schön und gut nach wie vor
bleibt aber das Problem mit den Kühlern
wir haben Thermostat bestellt und hoffen
dass es das ist müssen dafür Teile von
der Abgasanlage wieder rausnehmen können
das Thermostat dann tauschen und hoffen
dass sich das kühlerproblem dann löst
weil nach replight fahren wir haben
alles richtig gemacht es ist alles
wunderbar aber die Karre kühlt nicht
außerdem Kofferraum also vorne die
Motorhaube quasi geht über die Steuerung
aus dem Auto nicht auf und die
Klappensteuerung am Auspuff funktioniert
nicht da konnte uns gestern der sehr
sehr schlaue Rechner auch nicht bei
helfen das gilt es also auch noch zu tun
und ansonsten natürlich noch hier und da
ein paar Kleinigkeiten aber Innenraum
kommt wieder zusammen das Auto steht 1A
alles wunderbar Kühler vorne hinten den
ganzen Kram wieder rein dann schauen wir
mal im Innenraum war die grundsätzliche
Verkleidung schon fertig eingebaut
bedeutet wir können mit den GT3
typischen Teilen weiter machen bedeutet
Überrollkäfig rein schrotgurte rein und
vor allem die Carbon Schalensitze Alter
das Auto wird wieder zu einem Auto denn
der Fahrer kann quasi in 5 Minuten
wieder sitzen er kann noch nicht fahren
aber er kann wieder
sitzen Innenraum haben wir soweit durch
den Käfig haben wir über die letzten 15
Minuten auch schon eingebaut alles
wunderbar überhaupt keine Probleme mehr
Sitze rein und dann ist der Innenraum
quasi fertig basically ist dann alles
fertig außer dass das Auto nicht läuft
aber oh mein
Gott ich kann es nicht so richtig
glauben
[Musik]
Alter aber es wird nicht nur wieder
zusammengebaut unser geliebtes Heck dass
wir schon sieben oder acht mal
auseinander gebaut haben muss auch
wieder weichen bedeutet ducktail ab
Heckleuchten ab Heckschürze ab damit wir
an die Abgasanlage kommen von der auch
Teile weg müssen um den Einbau des
Thermostats schon mal
vorzubereiten so guten Morgen aus dem
porschzentrum Trier es geht weiter ein
nächster Tag heute geht's drum die
Problematik abzustellen mit dem
überhitzen also der Motor wurde warm und
die Kühler vorne sind kalt geblieben
dazwischen sitzt ein Thermostat das
haben wir jetzt neu eingebaut und jetzt
sollte hoffentlich auch wieder die
Kühler vorne warm werden und das Auto
sich dann halt selber temperieren können
der Motor an sich wird warm geht auf 90°
öffnet dann hier drin das Thermostat das
Thermostat schaltet dann praktisch da
eine Öffnung frei
dann kann hier durch diese Rohre einmal
bis nach vorne durch die Kühler
durchspült werden einmal vorne rum und
dann hier dururch wieder
zurück und somit sind d halt die Kühler
durchströmt und der Motor kann sich dann
halt richtig temperieren wenn man
natürlich lange Berg abfährt wird
natürlich die kümete Temperatur wieder
kälter also fällt unter die 70 80° und
dann macht das Thermostat wieder zu und
dann tut der Motor sich dann halt wieder
selberhitzen ansonsten würde die ganze
Motor Temperatur auch wieder runtergehen
dafür muss halt eben das Thermostat bzw
der kühlmittelregler da sein und das
dann halt ja temperieren zu können bzw
regeln zu können gestern haben wir dann
schon das kühmittel noch mal vollständig
abgelassen und ja jetzt tu ich das
befösystem anschließen und dann machen
wir das noch mal voll ziehen gut Vakuum
dass ich dann alles schön reinziehen
kann das neue Kühlmittel und dann sollte
das Auto hoffentlich nicht mehr zu warm
werden also schauen wir mal rein das
servicegerät ist angeschlossen am
kühsystem und jetzt starten wir den
[Musik]
vakuumvorgang ja sieht man auch richtig
schön wie sich alle Schläuche
zusammengezogen haben also ist richtig
Unterdruck drin ja jetzt wird
befüllt System befüllt das richtige
kühmittel 20
kg
und ja rein damit so das kümit ist jetzt
drin jetzt machen wir das Auto noch mal
an und stand lüftungsvorgang immer ein
Auge auf die Temperatur und hoffen dass
er diesmal nicht mehr zu warm
[Musik]
wird okay 84° der Moment der
Wahrheit
[Musik]
jawoh da kommt der Chef hallo moin also
ich war nicht ganz untätig ne okay h
gemacht echt und läuft
echt Alter hast wieder alles befüllt
allesin
Gott oh mein gott weiß du was das heißt
erste probefahr dass wir eine erste
Probefahrt machen können und dass ich
die Karre heute mitnehmen kann und das
hier das vorläufige na ja es ist noch
nicht das Ende ich habe mir noch ein
paar kleine Sachen überlegt aber wir
haben Freitag bedeutet es sind zwei Tage
Wochenende ich muss nichts tun außer den
ganzen Tag im Kreis zu fahren mit dieser
Karre oh mein
Gott vielen Dank warum geht die Scheiße
kaputt das ist unglaublich wir hauen die
Karre jetzt zusammen Unterboden drunter
Hitzeschutz Fläche
dran vergessen wie das heißt Stoßstange
ja und dann äh wird Gerit Alter direkt
erste
Kurve direkt wieder kaputt machen neues
Projekt ich repariere wieder mein 92 GT3
und ab diesem Zeitpunkt war klar dass
das Auto tatsächlich fertig wird was mir
unheimlich viel Druck genommen hat ich
habe so viel Geld für ein Auto
ausgegeben bei dem nicht klar war ob es
jemals wieder vernünftig im
Straßenverkehr teilnehmen kann das die
letzten anderthalb Monate von mir
bestimmt hat und fast wie ein eigenes
Kind von morgens bis abends
Aufmerksamkeit gebraucht und jetzt
stehen wir kurz davor die erste
Probefahrt zu machen und deswegen spanne
ich euch und mich nicht länger auf die
Folter wir schrauben zusammen machen
genau das eine Probefahrt so das Tor ist
offen es kann nur eins bedeuten Karre
steht quasi komplett zusammengebaut
hinter mir jetzt fehlt nur noch
achvermessung und Unterboden was wir
gleich machen aber als allererstes
müssen wir schauen ob technisch alles
funktioniert und deswegen setzen wir uns
jetzt das aller allererste Mal in diese
Karre und fahren Runde
[Musik]
Probefahrt ach du
scheiße oh mein
Gott oh mein
Gott oh mein Gott
Alter Alter krass alter
[Musik]
83° das ist okay oder sehr gut
ja oh mein Gott
oh mein
Gott oh mein Gott ach du
scheiße
oh mein Gott neben dem ganzen Spaß der
Testfahrt hat so eine Testfahrt aber
auch tatsächlich den Zweck Sachen zu
testen nämlich herauszufinden ob
irgendwelche Dinge noch nicht so
funktionieren wie wir oder Porsche sich
das vorstellt also natürlich alle
Bedieneinheiten am Lenkrad und fürs
Radio und so weiter Motor Getriebe kühlt
das Auto vernünftig gibt es irgendwelche
Geräusche die nicht sein sollen muss
noch irgendwas eingestellt werden im
Prinzip achtet man auf alles bremst
einmal ordentlich beschleunigt einmal
ordentlich und findet heraus wo noch
irgendwas geändert oder angepasst werden
muss da grundsätzlich aber alles in
bester Ordnung war und wirklich gut
funktioniert hat konnten wir uns um die
finalen Arbeiten kümmern die nötig sind
um wirklich alles perfekt zu haben
starten mit der Achsvermessung die
wichtig ist damit sich das Auto genauso
kontrollieren lässt wie es vorgesehen
ist natürlich soll das Auto bei einem
geraden Lenkrad nicht komisch nach links
oder rechts ziehen geschweige denn durch
ein falschen Sturz nur auf Teilen des
Rades aufliegen all das wie wird mit
diesem Gerät namens hawkey auf
Millimeter genaue Weise geprüft und dann
von den Jungs im Porsche Zentrum
eingestellt weil das Porsche Zentrum
indem der Verunfallte Porsche damals
eingeschleppt wurde und Teegarten schon
kontrolliert hatten dass weder Front
noch Heckachse krumm sind wissen wir
dass alles reparabel ist und wir das
Auto wieder genau perfekt einstellen
können sollte das nicht der Fall sein
und irgendwas krum sein Querlenker
irgendwas an der Achse oder sogar kaputt
gebrochen wie auch immer dann kann man
so viel einstellen wie man will man
bekommt es nicht wieder in
Werkseinstellung aber bei uns war alles
perfekt und das Auto steht wieder
schnurschnacks Schnur schnurschnacks
aber bei uns war alles perfekt und das
Auto steht wieder gerade fährt wieder
gerade und alles ist perfekt und zu
guter Letzt galt es das Auto von unten
zu schützen bedeutet Unterbodenschutz
dran Diffusor dran und dann
fertig so und zum Abschluss will ich
noch mal Danke sagen vielen Dank ans
Porschezentrum Trier Robin natürlich
ganz besonders der mich auch außerhalb
des des Porsche Zentrums unterstützt hat
aber das Porsche Zentrum Trier hat uns
ihre heiligen Hallen zur Verfügung
gestellt mit Robin um die Karre hier
wieder fixt zu bekommen Vielen Dank für
den Support an jeden einzelnen von euch
und eben ganz besonders ans Porsche
Zentrum Trier kommt hier vorbei wenn ihr
ein Porsche braucht wenn ihr was
umgebaut haben wollt wenn ihr was neues
sucht was gebraucht ist in neuem Zentrum
ab Februar ich habe auch eine quasi neue
Karre oh du darfst das nicht Karre
nennen mein Traumauto ist fertig wir
haben es tatsächlich hinbekommen den
günstigsten 992 GT3 Deutschlands wieder
aufzubauen und das ohne zu fuschen wir
haben an keiner Ecke gespart und er
steht wieder in Originalzustand da
worüber ich unheimlich happy bin
deswegen ein riesen Dankeschön noch mal
an jeden einzelnen der mir in diesem
Projekt geholfen hat der mit an dem
Wagen gearbeitet hat und ganz besonders
natürlich an euch durch die diese Serie
so unheimlich erfolgreich geworden ist
ach ja und für alle die genauso Porsche
begeistert sind wie ich checkt mein
zweitkanal aus Link ist in der
Videobeschreibung dort wird in nächster
Zeit ziemlich viel viel mit genau dem
Auto komm und jetzt bleibt mir nichts
anderes mehr zu sagen als viel Spaß und
genießt es ja was soll ich Euch erzählen
wir haben alles gegeben wir haben
probiert ein carporn zu drehen aber es
funktioniert nicht es liegt Schnee in
Köln wir haben 510 PS auf der Heckachse
und es funktioniert einfach nicht es
funktioniert so sehr nicht dass ich
gerade darauf warte von hier weggezogen
zu werden weil ich nicht mehr nach Hause
komme es ist allgatt und die Karre macht
nichts außer rutschen bedeutet ich lass
mich nach Hause ziehen in diesem Video
schaffen wir es nicht wir haben alles
gegeben funktioniert nicht dort steht
das Auto das mich jetzt Abschleppen wird
im nächsten Video gibt's dann den carpn
und die kostenauflistung also vergesst
nicht den Kanal zu
abonnieren